hey guys i gotta show you something real  quick  um  just for the hell of it publishing your  movie  it's fairly cpu intensive  just just letting you know  windows movie maker is not good at  managing your resources  it does use both cores because it's  built into windows  i'm only using 1.6 gigs of ram which is  great but  oh my god  it's using a hell of a lot of my cpu  and here's a little um  already a little taste of how much  of the cpu is using yes 100  percent  i'm going to go to my processes windows  movie maker is using  50  and the recording utility which is this  my you know studio right now is using  12  up to 25-ish percent of the cpu  look at that 149 megabytes  a kilobyte sorry 149 151 megabytes of  ram because it's 150 000  kilobytes peace out